ya lo do and that contain the video on
another 15 minute game going to play you
for I think I'm not yet one hundred
percent awake here so let's try with
afford to get me awake um if I've if
I've is somewhat unusual in this
position usually done the move that
supposed to refute this is Bishop b5 but
maybe this is also an underestimated
turn line okay let's go let's play this
first I still have the salsa so loud
okay need to exchange I now on I to f5 I
guess the Sun this should be the point
here well let's check quickly neither
five what could be the idea from blacks
point of you may be nigh def 693 and
then capture on your form something like
this could be
yeah but okay well should I go so let's
go neither five all other squares don't
make much sense okay is there something
else well let's check quickly 93 then it
takes on e4 94 greene takes at five okay
I could take these six Len but some
certainly is no huge advantage well
maybe maybe it just good for white hmm
the same is there something else
maybe f3 f3 d5 and then Bishop g5 if he
takes on e4 then I take f6 this could be
good for white ok let's let's try this
already cleared it behind on the clock
yeah my idea was d5 then Bishop g5 he
takes on a photograph six then he cannot
take on f5 because queen d 8 is
checkmate so he would need to recapture
on f6 with the porn and then I get this
tremendous knight on d5 on f5 and
basically my idea is to prevent him from
playing d5 at all maybe even using the
move c4 not sure one issue he is also ok
he goes 45 ok Bishop g5 was the idea not
sure if he has got something else it
could take it play deform but what still
I would get this great night on f5 now
maybe it's it's it's possible time to
exchange it with Nazi 67 ok but pretty
much obliged to do this now no big
choice
yeah of course what I don't like is in
general if I exchange on f6 okay damages
its pawn structure considerably but and
I get this night okay but whether the
dark square some a problem I already
played you for and f3 expecially and
this very much weakens the dark squares
so maybe he needs to go D for now allows
me to take on f6 otherwise he would just
lose a pawn or DD takes e4 some so I
think terrible end game for him well
maybe maybe one possibility could be
let's say it takes only 40 take on f6 G
takes f yeah I take only for myself yeah
yeah I was just thinking if I take
myself on the seven recruit captures
with sunlight and then maybe he's got 95
to get some counter play against the e4
pawn which is well isolated not
protected anymore bye bye am bi porn
yeah but this son this should be should
be good for me yeah he needs to play d4
I think not much of much else
what else could you try you could try to
sechrist sacrifice the d5 pawn of course
i could do that queen too i don't know
may be queen two is six or something in
order to recapture on f6 with the Queen
if I take that on f6 Queen f6 queen
takes d5 I cannot check with the porn as
a 55 for saying so Bishop f6 queen 06
queen d 5 and then maybe 96 trying to
get compensation with rook da to come
and maybe the dark squares this is not
not so well yeah maybe this as possible
it's not completely insane or something
still hard to imagine that you would
play this but yeah maybe deformed before
this is maybe not so awful for black
let's say I take on f6 do you take self
and how do I continue
this problem before i'm somewhat
retrieved restricts my pieces i don't
have a good square for the be one night
cannot go to c3 anymore and down maybe i
would like to have this night on d3 in
this structure with the hymn playing d
54 but this is a terribly long way yeah
it's basically impossible to to get the
night down yeah this isn't so bad but
he's thinking really hard or is he got
disconnected to try quickly too yeah we
both seem to be connected ok Iyaz
understandable that this is some an
important decision here that he needs to
make but still I think it doesn't hence
much as my husband does it has so many
alternatives to either just sacrifices
spawn with something like Queenie 6
Queenie 6 is designed to retake on f6
out with a piece so otherwise okay try
something something else yeah I thought
about this briefly as well
yeah yeah the idea would be now if I
take on f6 take on d5 then you would
take on d5 ed and night 29 to be four
and then D 5 D 5 would be would be
hanging as well as c 3 and c 2 also with
this fork thread so this is some
certainly am a viable option
yeah is there something better than
taking on f6 here in general what I'd
like to do is take on f6 and play 93 but
he's got Bishop before which is somewhat
annoying otherwise this would be very
good for me okay still let them let's
try to figure out the position after
Bishop f6 and 25 I'm bishop f6 GF 25
2585 night before then C 2 is of course
cause hanging hmm I don't have a really
good way to protect this
just well night a three which looks so
somewhat ugly of course let's say nine
txt five then and then the night c 4 i'm
not sure that i like this too much yeah
maybe 96 was a good move it
makes a good makes a fine impression
okay but still let's let's see um do I
have something else really taking 93
okay this Bishop before i could take
then on d5 but so also not that great
let's take here first 93 maybe but I
don't want to move this piece all so so
so many times idea would be to get it on
d5 but then somehow mine I don't be one
doesn't make any sense at all
yeah maybe this is a completely okay for
him if I don't establish your porn here
and then ok let think again and I think
again here does he doesn't threaten
anything really so can i prepare maybe
I'm taking or something I could I could
just cancel for instance I guess it's
never really an idea of them try them to
take on e for counseling maybe would
threaten Knight c3 in some way yeah 3 d
5 this is just just not so great the
position after exchanging that before
night a 395 I guess I have to play
Knight c4 and then I don't know my
Knights don't have source this position
of the lights are is not a lot very
stable somehow maybe I'm judging this
wrong but don't like it so much okay
let's cancel first
idea now is to play Knight c3 next move
trying to to get this piece to to d5
okay could of course play d4 now but
this was an option a couple of moves to
go anyway sound yeah this position is
not not so not so bad for black deform
also mine I don't be one is really
terrible after deform
it doesn't have really a good term a
good route 22 22 decent square
let's say note huh okay interesting
didn't really expect this one but isn't
necessarily bad or something Knight c3
know it takes on you for the next change
on d7 and could easily capture with the
night then but if I recapture with the
pawn he might have rook t2 which could
be a could be an annoying move
Queen takes d5 in this position
certainly somewhat better compared to
before but okay we need to speed up down
down somewhat on the clock now d 495
should just be fine for me maybe even
that is not so clear we need six or
something hmm okay bye d txt files now
the most logical or maybe the check
first not sure but it takes the form
yeah I need to stay really active here
with this the destroyed point
information on the king site he needs to
play active moose maybe d takes the form
trying to get something on d to let's
say d for Queen txt seven droop text e7
and F takes e4 he might just play rock d
2 I cannot really go look F 2 because of
Bishop c5 so I cannot easily get rid of
this rook and he might come up with Luke
g8 and Bishop c5 check and so on getting
some play on the G fire but first and
foremost after luke t 2 in this line I
need to cover see to somewhere and I
don't see how so maybe after details
before I can I could try to UM exchange
on g7 and then after rook takes um
capture on e4 with the night which maybe
is some the most solid option here
because t2 is just covered and still my
structure somewhat better yeah okay the
sum wasn't yeah need to go here where
should i go on the issue now could be
motive to like rook takes d5 and screen
takes f5 so okay not possible now with
in general this night's could could also
be a liability some sometimes
but okay now first thing they are nicely
positioned there of course yeah but it's
no it's not a threat yet so because
consists exceso hanging the interesting
a question here is how to continue he
might just try to take on d5 8525 maybe
this is yeah maybe this is even an idea
what I'm what I'm asking myself is what
is what about the move on c4 in this
position trying to really cement these
pieces if he takes up a song i would
just recapture with the pond and then i
might use the B file to to get something
against this King it would also once
more overprotect d5 so that this kind of
sacrifices should work yeah a very
interesting very interesting game yeah
still still I like this yeah I gives him
the space porn but i'm not sure the two
nights are really great and I should
have options of pushing my pawns here
and this point is and is it so dangerous
okay let's go down if it takes on c3 now
be takes c3 and rook t5 I can capture
with the Queen cell he cannot loosen the
grip of the Knights with an exchange
sacrifice so easily maybe you should
take and give this check on c5 win a
tempo and then proceed from there
I would then try to and get play on the
B file a group be one Queen fo and so on
I really think I'm he needs to take on
c3 this protected passport ID form maybe
looks nice at first sight yeah he agrees
that he needs to take but I guess he
needs to open up it open up the position
here and thats questionable of my beef
I'll play is so great
I'm you and a head on the clock happens
so rarely enough but it's been really AM
complicated battle here so it's very
understandable that he took some time
well what's nice here that black doesn't
has to have it doesn't have too much
play on its own okay he now yeah I don't
think this will hurt missing too much to
exchange one piece here the question is
what night should take could take with
the f5 night Bishop recaptures then he
maybe has got this idea of f5 but this
doesn't yay can play a five if it takes
it before I still have the F point to
recapture and then the rook would
prevent the further f5 I capture with
the d5 night he captures with the bishop
then queen bee three it should also be
somewhat better for me looks like the
more technical solution but I like the
device aren't really so but but did both
them both was looking fine so while f5
doesn't irritate me too much
ok let's try to get something on the B
file now I'm not sure how to proceed
this should threaten Quincy form and
also sort of over protect a 45 and so on
and next move could be also root B 5
rupee 1 and so on yeah now's the time to
to speed up a bit here down to 240 and
he's even below two minutes but he keeps
our investing lots of time
oh this is getting critical clockwise I
really hope it just doesn't let the time
run down and turn and let me win on time
so it's still not entirely clear I think
why did white should be much better but
it's it's the fighting position okay
let's go here
not sure how we protect the snow yeah
the Sun looks somewhat somewhat shaky
mmm
but there's no I'm direct refutation I
think Brooke be five maybe patek this
piece we retreat somewhere queen bee
three yeah well let's play a bit faster
here
I needs to retreat v6 South answered
with 97 winning the Queen so he needs to
go on Bishop p6 or something yeah well
be should be six looks like the only
move yeah he just fails to move okay
about down 97 yeah check yeah he just
completely broke down with with the time
getting getting getting down whoever it
was a very interesting positional fight
and not not clear at all I think so
black resigned yeah I did quite a good
good job defending this this position
think that's that's let's quickly recap
this game yeah this is what's the first
a critical position are quickly um yeah
the computer actually wants to take on
e4 and it's a stock with stop fish
engine I don't yet have Houdini
installed i'm just lazy butt stock which
assesses d take c for this kind of
position as 0 0 0 and this is just just
nonsense this is just clearly better for
white that's i don't i don't really care
what the engine is saying this and this
kind of position white is just clearly
better so I'm really really really wrong
assessment 96 yam the engine now wants
to take on f6 and play Knight c3 I
thought about this briefly Knight c3
Bishop before then take on d5 but I
didn't like the structure here maybe it
is better for white but ok let's let's
play on here
yeah now it gives a whiter 11 point
advantage a I guess this is about the
correct assessment it wants to take on
e4 now this this is just difficult
difficult yeah this is rather tip is
very interesting to to check here the
computer suggestions because it's some
moves out completely in you may need you
just it just wants to play a 3 here and
well you simply don't play this this way
because a 3 black can take on d5 ed 525
and he gets on one point for the
exchange and breaks down the control
here that white has in this position of
both the d5 and the f5 Square and this
is ridiculous you don't you don't allow
and rook takes d5 if you um if you don't
really need two and A three it wants to
yeah it wants to play rook g8 and then
then sacrifice the exchange it assesses
the position has somewhat better for
wide which is may be true but still this
deceased nights are just too too good to
to to allow them to be M broken up with
with an exchange sexo see far as I think
a good move keeping them keeping the
night saved them and yeah computer here
doesn't want to take on c3 empezar
complain king be eight but then a three
before and so on why should be much
better than
check check yeah compare place queen bee
three yeah this is better you
threatening on b7 first and then Quincy
for but white widest is better here no
question but of course what would he
also completely failed to to just make
moves in it just at some point you just
need to move okay t100 to blend it is
Queen I'm very interesting struggle here
I think he defended well first first off
maybe here in this position you
shouldn't castle but but play deform
here here deform preventing my night
from getting a good square and I'm not
quite sure what what i should do there
because why does this night go it would
have a good position on d3 maybe maybe
one night but this is ridiculously long
way like D 2 D 2 B 3 c1 d3 this is
terribly slow and in the meantime we can
easily challenge their 59 with 97 this
is perfectly okay i think for black it's
not not at all a problem yeah very
interesting very interesting i'm not
sure but considering i concerning the
opening i don't i don't really know this
so it's there some some other issue here
should i go to f5 may be in order to
somehow refute this
maybe just 92 well Knight c3 here can
you can really take on leaf or maybe
maybe this is some some really weird
stuff half maybe maybe the issue here is
93 Knight takes e4 90 x g7 check Bishop
g7 Knight takes e4 d5 Bishop h6
something like this this could be the
problem this is a known motive in this
kind of kind of setup I'm not sure I'd
really need to learn how to how to
examine here to to to play some moves
I'm not sure how to do this really
all right let's try quickly maybe i can
i can figure this out when i was at
least i can do this what I were thinking
about is this here capture here before
and if he wants to get rid of the night
now I have this nice shot this is some
this is known idea for instance and the
Charis attack of the scavenging and
white as the extra move g four and a six
would be the extra boost here but he a
does here didn't have g four played for
instance takes here but no idea was this
refutation hard to believe yeah okay i
can analyze this all day yeah thanks for
watching i think it was a really nice a
nice game with good content and what's
it tuned i hope i do one or two more
videos today